traigo conmigo un billete mágico que me
gustaría regalar pero se preguntarán por
qué es mágico
bueno pues porque si lo tuvieras en tus
manos serías capaz de lograr todo
aquello que más deseas en la vida quien
lo quiere
veo que muchos ha levantado la mano eso
es bueno ahora se van a imaginar que eso
siento es su zona de confort
sabiendo los poderes mágicos que tenía
este billete te pregunto por qué no
viniste a mí que te lo impidió
me puedo imaginar lo que acaba de pasar
hace unos instantes por su mente y si me
levanto y me regañen y si es una broma y
no me lo da realmente no le va a dar
y si y si y si algo a lo que yo le llamo
el diálogo del miedo que es precisamente
ese que se da cuando tenemos que
salirnos de nuestra zona de confort e ir
tras lo que queremos
esta actividad la quise compartir con
ustedes porque ya le divide en tres
ocasiones diferentes
cada una con un resultado muy distinto
la primera
yo también levanten y manos lo más alto
que yo pude pero qué sucede que mi
sorpresa es que al voltear a ver un
muchacho se levantó de su asiento se fue
directamente hacia el estrado y lo tomó
y la vida me enseñó que desear no es
suficiente hay que actuar
la segunda ocasión venga yo ya conocía
la dinámica entonces camine sin dudar
fui hacia el billete lo tomé y sonreí
porque esta vez había actuado y no
solamente deseado
pero la tercera vez que creen que me
sucedió
efectivamente me levanté y camine
sin embargo estando a punto de tomar mi
premio
me di la media vuelta y me fui a sentar
y me senté que sucedió dude
a tentar me el coach con el que estaba
me dijo gaby que hiciste e
inmediatamente después lanzó una
pregunta que revolucionó a mi mente me
dijo cuántas veces en tu vida has estado
a punto de lograr lo que tanto deseas y
por miedo te has dado la media vuelta
regresa te
por su tono de voz les prometo que
sentía coraje tristeza e impotencia
bueno hasta ganas de aventarle la silla
en la que me había sentado
pero he de confesar que si efectivamente
el miedo me venció que me controló y a
raíz de eso empecé a cuestionarme
cuántas veces he sentido miedo y no lo
reconocido es más que significa miedo
para mí
con estas ganas fervientes de construir
una definición le pregunté a amigos
familiares conocidos que significa miedo
para ustedes me dijeron tantas cosas me
dijeron gabi es una barrera mental algo
que nos impide avanzar algo que nos
limita que nos daña pero también hubo
quien me dijo que el miedo es el inicio
de nuevos retos incluso podría llegar a
ser nuestro amigo
continúa investigando y me encuentran
louis carrete este señor es máster en
neurociencia y dice que el miedo es la
reacción inmediata del organismo ante un
estímulo amenazante que tiene dos
componentes uno psicológico y otro
fisiológico
quien de todos tiene la razón
por supuesto que cada uno incluso mi
pequeño niño de cinco años que cuando le
pregunté se me acerca me dice en voz
bajita y al oído mamá es que el miedo es
la obscuridad las películas de payasos y
de chucky
lo que voy aprendiendo con todas estas
definiciones es que el miedo nunca se va
de nuestra vida que siempre está
presente y solamente se va transformando
según nuestra edad nuestro contexto o
nuestras experiencias y en lo dice
stephen covey que cuando abrimos la boca
para definir aquello que vemos nos
definimos a nosotros mismos
yo estoy convencida que todos aquí han
sabido identificar al menos una
situación de miedo por ejemplo ya
estamos bien acostados cómodos en cama
pero empezamos a escuchar ruidos en el
patio de la casa por la noche que
hacemos
inmediatamente nos levantamos y
prendemos las luces porque el miedo eso
es lo que hace
nos alerta
otra ocasión podría ser cuando hemos
estado a nada de un accidente
automovilístico o qué sensación tan fea
sientes como si toda la sangre se
concentra en el estómago ya veces
tenemos que incluso estacionarnos para
poder recuperar el aliento
bueno y otro tipo de miedo que muchos no
me van a negar es cuando nos llega el
estado de cuenta la tarjeta de crédito
pero el miedo no únicamente se encuentra
en esos momentos y mi pequeña niña de 11
años me lo hizo ver
mientras platicaba yo con ella este tema
me dijo mamá es que el miedo está con
nosotros aún cuando somos muy felices
para la edad que tiene llegar a esa
conclusión
me impactó cuánta razón tiene porque no
únicamente está en ese mensaje de texto
que no hemos enviado por miedo al
rechazo o en ese negocio que no hemos
emprendido por miedo al fracaso
tal vez en esa carta de renuncia que ya
redactamos pero no hemos entregado por
miedo al qué dirán
el miedo también está presente en el
nacimiento de nuestros hijos en los
viajes que estamos por realizar incluso
en el torneo que estamos por jugar
el miedo es muy astuto y la mayoría de
las veces se disfraza de complejos
prejuicios pero solamente podremos
identificarlo
cuando nos respondemos auténticamente
una pregunta quién soy claro si queremos
enfrentar nuestros miedos tenemos que
saber cuáles son nuestras debilidades
nuestras fortalezas que nos hace feliz y
qué no
continuando con esta investigación del
miedo me topo con una frase de freud que
dice que nuestra mayor debilidad es la
fuente
de nuestra fuerza
digo cómo pueden aplicar yo esto qué
pasa si mi mayor debilidad la transforma
en una gran aliada que me impulsa a
lograr mis metas
les platicaré de tres miedos muy
específicos
el primero fue el haber renunciado a mi
trabajo
tenía que dejar lo que era completamente
seguro para mí porque había decidido
dejar de sobrevivir y comenzar a vivir
mis sueños
el segundo miedo vencido fue el haber
posada en traje de baño ante una cámara
porque normalmente cuando iba yo a la
playa lo hacía con el traje de baño pero
con una blusa cuatro veces más grande
que yo o con un enorme short
todo porque no quería que me vieran no
quería que vieran mis defectos
ese momento fue un reto porque tuve que
quitarme todos los complejos de gorda
como la vergüenza y el que dirán y
aventarlos por la borda
el tercer miedo vencido fue el haber
entrado nuevamente un probador de ropa
tiran gabi está tan fácil
pero realmente no lo era para mí porque
ese pequeño espacio era mi infierno
terrenal de donde salía llorando después
de haberme golpeado y todo porque un
pedazo de tela claro el que estaba de
moda y el que me gustaba novia de mi
talla no había para gordas
como decido enfrentar a estos miedos
decido emprender
decido crear un lugar mágico lleno de
colores texturas diseño donde las
mujeres como yo no sintiera miedo para
ir a comprar ropa donde nos salieran con
las tantas frases de no me gusta pero me
queda o si me gusta una de cada color
por favor no sí sino que al salir de ahí
se sintieran capaces de cualquier cosa
eso sí tuve que ser congruente conmigo
misma y con todas las decisiones que ya
había tomado
me costó mantenerme firme
porque aun cuando la angustia la
ansiedad y las dudas me quitaban el
sueño continué
yo estaba consciente que al enfrentar
todos mis miedos tenía una de dos
opciones de resultado el éxito o el
fracaso y que debía estar preparada para
ambos porque porque el éxito de ser
continuo me llevaría nuevamente a mi
zona de confort
por lo contrario el fracaso me llevaría
un reto mucho mayor
hoy quiero que recuerden recuerden todas
esas primeras veces que sintieron mucho
miedo el primer día en la escuela que no
podían no podíamos ni dormir en la noche
la primera entrevista de trabajo tu
primer empleo
tu primer hijo tu primer beso y mejor
dejémoslo ahí
hoy quiero confesarles que esta es la
primera vez que doy una charla de esta
magnitud y que me he consumido en miedo
desde la primera palabra que pronuncie
mi debilidad antes de todo el
entrenamiento solía pensar que no era
nada buena expresándome y me atreví a
hacerlo y estoy aquí frente a ustedes
de mostrándome nuevamente de lo que soy
capaz
yo te invito te invito a que analices
cuál es su definición de miedo observa
que está diciendo de ti
atrévete a descubrir tu mayor debilidad
y transformarla en tu aliada y a partir
de ese momento yo te aseguro que nadie
absolutamente nadie podrá contra ti
muchas gracias